as they want to administer more and more
vaccines but simply don't have the
supply while they hope for more they are
working to improve the current
vaccination sites
joe mohler live at cashman center the
largest site with more on this hi joe
hey there brian today we're trying to
get some answers to the questions that
many of you have been having regarding
the vaccination rollout here in clark
county we know many people are still
frustrated
with trying to book an appointment well
the county says they're trying to give
out as many vaccines as possible but
they are limited
due to how many they get each week what
we really want to do is get more vaccine
out to the community
clark county and the southern nevada
health district are making improvements
to the largest vaccination site at
cashman center
there's a new registration process
that's in place
that we think is going today it's
showing that it's improved things
already
cashman was closed over the weekend now
there is a new registration process for
those with appointments
it will speed up the time it takes to
get to the vaccine before the wait was
up to two hours now you arrive with a qr
code after making the appointment
we use the ipads that we have now they
scan that qr code
and that pulls that patient information
up right away
the biggest issue booking an appointment
right now appointments are only being
accepted 72 hours in advance due to the
amount of vaccines
i mean i don't want people sitting there
all day refresh refresh refresh refresh
that's not a great way to live your life
right but to check back often
if you are trying to book a second dose
appointment according to the health
district you will be notified to make
that appointment by the contact
information provided
our biggest hurdle right now is the
amount of vaccines that we have
this week clark county is getting
roughly 23 000 vaccines
while they can administer four times
that across the valley
they can't due to the amount of vaccines
they receive our message is
send us more vaccines
according to the health district so far
here in southern nevada roughly 22 000
second doses have been administered well
if you received your first dose here
at cashman you will not be getting that
second dose at cash and there will be
another location for the second dose
the health district has yet to announce
where that location will be
reporting live at caption center joe
mullen 8 news now